I have bettajeed by AOR, 100 milligrams, is that the same?
So bettajeed, okay, let me pull it up a little bit, remember doses of all these things.
So you have the bettajeed, so the bettajeed is oxaloacetate at 100 milligrams, yeah?
That's where we were talking about oxaloacetate.
So you have the bettajeed, bettajeed is, bettajeed, understand, the same company makes both of these just under the different label.
So bettajeed is the 100 milligrams of oxaloacetate, all right?
So the oxaloacetate CFS is, and this is, and understand, the bettajeed is 100 milligrams per two capsules.
So it's two capsules per day, gives, honestly, I'm going to go back, whoa, that's right.
So the bettajeed is 100 milligrams per capsule, that's what it is, 100 milligrams per capsule, but there's 30 capsules per bottle.
The oxaloacetate is 500 milligrams per capsule, and there's 90 capsules per bottle.
So it is literally, it's a lot less expensive to use, not a lot, but it is less expensive to use.
If you're going to buy a whole lot of bottles of the bettajeed, they just, they just literally formulated it to the study of taking 1500 milligrams per day.
So if you were going to take 1500 milligrams a day of oxaloacetate CFS, you're taking three capsules a day, one of the boardy, one of the night.
If you're taking 1500 milligrams of the bettajeed, you're taking five of the boardy, five at night, a bottle in only last two days.
So you can see it's going to actually be a whole lot more expensive.
So they formulated the oxaloacetate to last you a month.
There's 90 capsules per bottle taken at three a day last to one month.
So that's the difference.
So 100 milligrams is one capsule and they're recommended 1500 milligrams per day is what the study was for breast cancer.
So hopefully that helps.
It's a little confusing with some of these things.
So the oxaloacetate CFS is what it's called.
Right now they can only label it for chronic fatigue syndrome.
The FDA came after them, made them take down their astrocytoma study, even though they had a peer reviewed study for astrocytoma, which is a brain cancer.
And they had peer reviewed study for breast cancer.
The FDA made them take it off.
We can't put that on our site.